véronique est chaîne praticien
hospitalier en infectiologie et
pédiatres et unique et chaîne merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors pour commencer
quelles sont précisément ces fameux
symptômes chez des enfants qui suscite
l'incompréhension
alors en fait il s'agit effectivement
comme ça a été dit d'une maladie de
kawasaki qui est une maladie que les
pédiatres connaissent bien et depuis
donc peu de temps là depuis je dirais un
mois on a quelques cas de plus que on a
l'habitude de voir ça c'est la première
chose et la deuxième chose c'est que
c'est cassant un peu sans moi typique de
ce qu'on connaissait jusque-là donc
comme tout le monde on se pose la
question si ça pourrait avoir un lien
avec le co vide 19 et c'est la raison
pour laquelle l' alerte entre guillemets
est parti et qu'on essaye de comprendre
ce qui se passe alors on parle d'un
olivier de la maladie de kawasaki
quelle forme peut-elle prendre chez les
enfants alors c'est une maladie rare
c'est une maladie qui est bien connue
des pédiatres qui les dunes à une
inflammation non contrôlée de du système
immunitaire en fait qui s'active
beaucoup trop et qui peut donner d
inflammation cardiaque donc ça c'est la
maladie de kawasaki typique en fait
elles donnent plutôt des inflammations
de des vaisseaux cardiaques des
vaisseaux coronaires parfois dans la
maladie de kawasaki on peut aussi avoir
associé une maladie du myocarde donc une
inflammation myocardique et ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle la myocardite et c'est sur
ce critère là qu'on a un peu plus quand
qu'on a eus l'alertant qu'il y avait un
peu plus ni eau car dit ces derniers
temps quand on a l'habitude de voir lors
de cette saison en sachant que la
maladie de kawasaki est une maladie qui
apparaît habituellement au printemps et
dont on ne connaît au jour d'aujourd'hui
toujours pas la cause est ce que l'on
sait justement vous parliez d'une
maladie rare combien d'enfants sont
concernés chaque année
et là est ce que le nombre de cas
constatés justement ces dernières
semaines et est vraiment anormal
alors ce qui est anormal c'est le nombre
de cas a ramassé sur une coupe une
période un peu plus courte
donc c'est vrai que dans un service de
pédiatrie générale standard en voix
3-4 jusqu'à 10 ça dépend de la taille du
service de pédiatrie générale syndrome
de kawasaki par par an donc j'ai pas ce
que ça fait sur sur l'ensemble de la
france mais ça doit être entre 500 et
1000 cas par pas par an en france et
donc là c'est le fait que c'est sur les
15,3 de quinze derniers jours trois
semaines dernières semaines quand on a
eu un peu plus on a trouvé que j'en
avais un peu plus c'est pour ça que
l'alerté partie alors en quoi un lien
est possible avec le co vite 19 avec les
connaissances que l'on a aujourd'hui sur
ce fameux virus alors le coc u19 est une
maladie qui entraîne une maladie
inflammatoire en fait qui rend un peu le
système immunitaire trop réactif trop un
peu comme si le système unitaire ce qui
nous défend en fait l'armée qui nous
défend comme si elle devenait un peu
folle ça c'est déjà quelque chose qui
est connu chez les adultes que beaucoup
de manifestations que les eaux du ltte
ont lorsqu'ils ont une forme grave
c'est lié au système immunitaire qui est
trop trop actif
donc on surveillait sa aussi chez
l'enfant bien sûr on essayait de voir si
les enfants pouvaient être à risque
aussi d'avoir une inflammation un peu
plus élevée et donc cette alerte est
venue un peu dans ce contexte et c'est
la raison pour laquelle on doit
absolument vérifier si c'est une maladie
de kawasaki un peu atypique en ce moment
parce qu'il ya autre chose ou s'il ya
effectivement un lien avec le coguic 19
parce que comme vous l'avez très bien
dit dans votre reportage juste avant
c'est que il ya certains patients qui
ont été testés positifs mais on a aussi
beaucoup qui n'ont été testés négatifs
donc pour l'instant on ne sait pas si
c'est lié donc c'est on est à 1 au stade
de de se poser la question si ça
pourrait être lié à l'or en tout cas
maintenant qu'elle est le protocole un
qui doit être mise en place pour
surveiller au plus près ces nouveaux cas
très concrètement qu'est ce qui va se
passer alors très concrètement ce qui
est en train de se passer c'est que les
sociétés de les sociétés savantes ce
qu'on appelle les sociétés savantes de
pédiatrie se sont mis tous ensemble
aujourd'hui sur plusieurs réunions pour
développer
une un outil informatique qui permet de
compter tous les cas suspects ensuite il
y aura un conseil scientifique derrière
fait de pédiatres qui va analyser tout
ce qui a été remonté dans ce dans ce
tout y informatique pour savoir s'il
pourrait y avoir un lien et surtout
comparé au nombre de maladie de kawasaki
qu'on a eu les années précédentes savoir
si vraiment il ya une alerte supérieur
alors on comprend aujourd'hui beaucoup
de parents était tracassé par par cette
information
comment sais tu as l'air doit-elle être
prises en compte doit talent est vécue
pour le dans ce processus de retour à
l'école qui est en train de s'ouvrir
alors je pense que ce qui est ce que là
qu'on doit comprendre c'est que le
l'enfant on a des études qui montrent
que l'enfant est peu contagieux donc en
fait l'ouverture des écoles s'est fait
dans ce cadre là et on commence par
ouvrir les écoles des petits donc en
fait élémentaire et les laits maternels
parce qu'on sait que l'enfant porte le
virus peut dans son nez donc on sait que
les enfants entre eux sont probablement
peu contagieux il ya différentes études
qui prouvent ça on sait aussi
aujourd'hui contrairement à ce qu'on
pensait au début d'un pin et mick ce qui
est dangereux pour l'enfant c'est
l'adulte qui l'entourent donc moi mon
message va être que pour si vous voulez
vraiment protéger votre enfant il faut
faire en sorte que le virus ne rentre
pas à l'intérieur de votre foyer parce
que les mesures barrières ne sont pas
applicables à l'intérieur d'un domicile
alors que les mesures barrières sont
tout à fait applicable dans une école
surtout si c'est comme c'est un 10 qui
aura une dizaine d'enfants par classe et
que ça va être extrêmement organisés
merci beaucoup véronique elle chaîne
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes praticiens
hospitaliers infectiologues en
infectiologie
mais également pédiatre ça